if you want to hang out and talk about
anime theories recommendations and other
fun stuff feel free to join us on
discord and twitch both links are in the
description what is up everybody its
Anna Mack here for anime uproar and in
this video we will be talking about
Goku's mastered or perfected ultra
instinct form and why his hair becomes
silver or whitish gray once he attained
the mastered version of ultra instinct
as you may know if you've been following
this channel for a while for many months
I've been saying that Goku's final form
in Dragon Ball super would have white or
silver hair and I also made a video
about ultra instinct in particular in
which I argue that the ultra instinct
version we first saw was not the
mastered version and that Goku would
have another form beyond this my very
first video talking about why I think
Goku's final form would have white or
silver hair was made back in September
of 2017 and then in October of 2017 I
made a video talking about every Saiyan
transformation in which I included
Goku's ultra instinct form after getting
a ton of comments saying ultra instinct
is a technique it's not a Saiyan
transformation I responded by making a
video called Goku's ultra instinct is
not what we thought this video was
published in November of 2017 and in it
I argued that Goku's ultra instinct was
part of a unique new transformation and
that there would be more transformations
to come and since it was officially
announced that Goku's mastered ultra
instinct we'll have silver hair I have
been getting a ton of comments about how
I was right and how I called it way
before it was actually announced and I
appreciate all those comments guys thank
you and in this video I will be talking
about the real reason that Goku hair
becomes silver and I will be talking
about how I was able to predict the true
nature of ultra instinct as well as how
I knew that more changes were coming
including the silver or white hair I'll
be getting into that in a sec but if you
enjoyed the Dragon Ball super content on
this channel be sure to leave a like to
let me know if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell and we are now posting daily on
Twitter and Instagram so feel free to
follow us there at anime uproar let's
start things off with ultra instinct
itself earlier on and super we stels us
that ultra instinct is a technique that
allows the body to move in battle
without thinking and we know that other
characters have been seen using this
technique in the anime and manga so we
know that ultra instinct is certainly
not unique to say it but there was
always something different about Goku's
ultra instinct yes goku uses the
technique known as ultra instinct but he
also transforms in order to use it
effectively he actually attains a new
form which allows him to use ultra
instinct a form which changes his
appearance his eyes changed color and
become silver his aura becomes
completely different and the first time
he transforms his voice seems to echo
just like it did when he first attained
the Super Saiyan form in the original
Japanese dub whenever we see and beerus
used the ultra instinct technique their
appearance does not change but goku
actually transforms in order to use it
so he does attain a new form this new
form is most commonly referred to as
ultra instinct omen which is how it is
named in the dragon ball z dokkan battle
game to further emphasize that Goku's
ultra instinct is not the same as just a
regular ultra instinct technique when
Goku first achieves this new form both
the grand priest and wheeze are not sure
what exactly is happening now both of
these guys are obviously very familiar
with ultra instinct and they realize
that Goku is now able to use this
technique but there is also something
unique about Goku's transformation for
example wheeze is actually surprised by
the massive amount of heat that Goku is
generating in this state and then an
episode 115 as Goku is about to
transform during his battle with calf
law we see him using the ultra instinct
technique to dodge Kepler's attacks
before he fully transforms into this new
form when I first saw this it clicked
for me right away ultra instinct is a
technique that Goku is learning to use
but he is learning to use it with the
help of a new transformation this
transformation has varying degrees which
means that there might be another degree
or level beyond what we've seen so far
Goku's ultra instinct Omen form is more
than just the ultra instinct technique
and if we accept that Goku's ultra
instinct omen goes beyond just a
technique then the question is what is
the true nature of this new form what is
its true power and potential I argued
that this could be the first
transformation in a brand new family of
transformations a form which will have
its own Super Saiyan version just like
the Super Saiyan God form has the Super
Saiyan blue after all we did get some
big hints including the fact that the
word omen means a sign of things to come
so my theory was that ultra instinct
omen is just the first step and that
Goku will attain a new level altogether
and on top of that I speculated that in
this new form
Goku's hair would be silver or white now
the question is why silver instead of
some other color
why would silver hair in particular be
chosen for what might be go coos final
form in Dragon Ball super is there some
meaning behind this color or is it just
random in my previous videos I argued
that there is a clear reason for why the
creators of Dragon Ball super will most
likely decide on silver or white back in
the 1990s after Dragon Ball GT ended a
drawing of a Super Saiyan 5 form fooled
a lot of Dragon Ball fans they thought
that this drawing was a leak from Japan
and that this Super Saiyan 5 form would
be introduced sometime in the future
however it turned out that this was just
a fan-made
image that came from Spain but one thing
that I really liked about this fan-made
form is that it was drawn with silver or
white hair and I'm not
the creators of Dragon Ball super
decided to directly copy this fan made
image but the fact is that silver or
white hair has a lot of symbolic meaning
in Japanese culture and this has often
been translated into anime anime
characters with white or silver hair
often have mystical otherworldly or
godly powers there are many examples of
this in modern anime including ginkgo
from mushishi inuyasha Kannada from
Angel Beats and UA from Cardcaptor
Sakura in Japanese culture this hair
color symbolizes wisdom self-control
discipline purity Awakening and new
beginnings in our own non anime world
the hair color of people changes as they
get older and so your hair color goes
from whatever its natural color is to
gray and white
for this reason silver hair symbolizes
wisdom since as they get older people
become more experienced they gain more
knowledge and so they are seen as
becoming wiser now I don't know if this
will be Goku's final form since we are
not sure about the future of Dragon Ball
super but if this is goal Coos final
form it makes sense for his hair to turn
silver because this is the hair color
that people have in the final stage of
their life and this is the stage of
their lives in which they are the most
experienced knowledgeable and wise on
top of the symbolic and cultural meaning
of this color there is also a more
scientific method that I use to predict
that Goku's final form will look like
this we know that Goku Super Saiyan God
form has red hair and it actually
reminds me a lot of flames or fire and
Super Saiyan blue which is the Super
Saiyan transformation combined with the
Super Saiyan God form has blue hair an
interesting scientific fact is that blue
flames burn hotter than red flames so it
makes sense for Super Saiyan blue to be
the higher form in this case but here's
the thing the absolutely hottest flames
possible burn a blue-white color they
are blue around the outer edges and
white at the core closest to the source
of the flame so using this flame analogy
in previous videos I predicted that as
Goku moves beyond Super Saiyan blue his
hair will move beyond the color blue and
move closer to white in Dragon Ball
super in particular silver and white
hair has already been established as
something that many powerful characters
possess now Zeno and jiren are both bald
so we can't include them but we know
that the grand priests and the angels
some of the most powerful creatures
other than Zeno himself and also the
masu infused Hamas who all have white
hair the masu also has silver eyes just
like Goku in his ultra instinct form so
again I saw that as a potential clue
about where the creators were heading
when it comes to gold whose final form
so to sum things up the real reason that
Goku hair becomes silver is because
ultra instinct omen the first ultra
instinct formed the goku attains is not
the final ultra instinct form there was
more to Goku's ultra instinct
transformation than we first realized
there was another level to it and in
this higher level his hair turned silver
and why silver instead of some other
color because silver and white have a
lot of symbolic meaning in Japanese
culture and also potentially because of
that whole hottest flame analogy but we
can't know for sure as far as that goes
that's just kind of my own theory now
let me know what you guys think are you
now satisfied that Goku's ultra instinct
goes beyond just a technique and that it
is indeed a full-fledged transformation
also are you happy with the decision to
make go whose hair silver or would you
have preferred a different option and if
you're going to say that you would have
preferred to see something along the
lines of Super Saiyan for happening
super I agree completely
I love the Super Saiyan 4 form I love
the design unfortunately it doesn't look
like we're going to be getting anything
along those lines at least for now
finally do you think that this silver
Goku will be Goku's final form or do you
think that Dragon Ball super will
continue after a hiatus and that
eventually we are going to see even more
forms and even more transformations let
me know down in the comment
if you enjoy the Dragon Ball super
content on this channel be sure to leave
a like to let me know if you're new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell just a
quick note I want to thank all of you
who have been sending us your fan art on
Twitter and Instagram I will try to
feature your art at the end of our
videos and I will include the links to
your social media in the description so
everyone who sees the video can check
you guys out if they're interested
please continue to send us your stuff at
anime uproar on Twitter and Instagram
finally feel free to join us on discord
if you want to discuss anime theories
recommendations and more on a daily
basis as always thank you all so much
for watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]